[Music]
good morning
let me start with a question what do you
think is the most important aspect of
using r successfully
is being able to write high performance
code or making beautiful graphics
or perhaps learning how to write our
packages like here's my take on it
i think the most important aspect of
using r successfully
is being able to find and choose the
right tools for the job that you're
working on
i think a lot of data science projects
they got stuck or they're not as
successful as they could be because they
chose the wrong tools in the project to
build on
and once you've gone with a certain tool
it can be very hard to go back and fix
that
my name is jeroen ohms i've written
quite a few r packages some of which you
may have used
i'm also the maintainer of the compilers
in the build infrastructure for
our own windows and i'm a staff member
of the our openside group at uc berkeley
and within our open side we're working
on a big ambitious new project called
our universe and in essence our universe
is a open platform
based on git for managing personal r
package repositories
so that means that once a package is
registered the system will automatically
build binaries and documentation
and so on directly from git every time
the package author
push and update and these can be
our packages that are also on cran or
bioconductor or just your personal art
packages
and that really doesn't matter as long
as the source code is a bit is available
from git
however publishing packages is actually
not the goal of this project
more importantly it is a starting point
for us
to experiment with calculating metrics
and
showing other background information
about a package
that may tell us something about the
health
and the role and the impact of a
particular project
so towards the end of this talk i will
briefly explain
what our universe does and where this is
coming from
but mostly today i want to talk about
why we believe it is important to have
better tooling to actively monitor the
status and the health of research
software
because i think there are some important
differences between using open source
software and commercial software
that are not always immediately obvious
in particular when it comes to
expectations
about the quality and the life cycle
and the participation in open source
projects
so i hope to make you think a little bit
about
things you may want to consider when
you're going to use open source software
and some indicators that you may want to
look for in a healthy project
so how do we discover and choose the
best r packages
because r is amazing and you can do so
many cool things with it
and there's very few rules or
limitations but this also makes
our ecosystem sometimes feel a bit like
the wild west of research software
where it can be very hard to find the
good stuff or to judge if something is
trustworthy
suppose you're a data scientist and you
need to do a particular analysis or you
need to
read a particular file format or you
need an http client
to interface to some open data web
servers
like how do you know what's out there
and how do you know if it's any good
well maybe you find an article or a blog
post that mentions an interesting
package
so you read the description you maybe
wrote an example and
it seems to work so problem solved right
well as you probably know anyone can
create an art package
you just put your code into the right
format and then you put it up on github
or you submit it to cran
and cram will actually check if the
package can be installed on windows and
mac and linux
and if it does not violate any policies
but that's about it
there's no gatekeeping or judgment
on the contents of the r package and
this is what makes opensource software
so great because
anyone can participate but obviously
the quality of these contributions can
vary
and what is perhaps less obvious at
first
is that different package authors have
very different
ideas on what you can expect from them
in terms of maintenance and support and
participation
and these things become more relevant as
you start using are more seriously
of course when you're just playing
around for a homework assignment or a
one-off problem you just do whatever
works and move on
but if you start to really depend on a
package
i think the dynamic changes a bit i
suppose you're really going to build on
our package
in your dissertation research or your
company's data pipeline
at some point you should probably ask
yourself some questions like who made
this package
what's their background is this an
expert what other things have they made
and how can you trust the results are
correct has there been any peer review
or scientific publication to accompany
this package
like is it reliable does it get tested a
lot
because if it works for one example that
doesn't always mean it's going to work
for
any data and what if you have a question
about the software or you find a bug
is the maintainer going to be available
to help you
is the project still actively developed
and what are the maintenance
expectations
is the package even going to be around
three years from now when you plan to
finish your dissertation
and who else is using the software is
this like an established project
is there a large user community where
you can maybe ask questions
so what you do not want is that you
become fully dependent on a piece of
software
in your research or in your business and
then at some point a problem arises
and you run into really bad bug or the
thing is crashing or
it's depending on some other thing that
has been retired
or it just doesn't work anymore on the
latest version of windows or mac
and then it turns out there is no issue
tracker and then you contact the
maintainer but you get no response
or worse you get a response like well
this package is part of a research
project that no longer exists
and i've since then transferred to
another university and i don't have time
to work on this anymore
and this happens a lot i've certainly
been there and it's good to remember
that the package author really
doesn't owe you anything like most
maintainers are very nice and very
friendly
and they're very interested in helping
you while also using your feedback to
improve their package
like that is what open source software
is all about but sometimes you find
out that some software that you were
using may actually not be in very good
shape
i think a lot of this also comes down to
the unique life cycle of research
software
like all software has a life cycle but
for open source projects this
is often somewhat unclear and
unpredictable
like most projects start out as an
experiment and then a small fraction of
those projects
if it works well and the maintainer has
enough time to put into it
it may gradually develop into a mature
established piece of software
but eventually one day all software
becomes obsolete and it gets retired or
replaced with something better
and in commercial products there's
usually a license that states that you
know this product is officially
supported until at least 20 blah blah
blah but in open source projects there's
no such thing things are supported
basically
for the extent and the duration that the
author has an interest in maintaining
that thing
for example a lot of research software
only exists as a proof of concept to
accompany a scientific paper and once
the thing has been published the author
has really no intention
of ever touching the software again so
if you want to actually
build on that software then you're
basically on your own
but many are packages these days they
are the exact opposite
and they are not published for their
scientific merit but they do something
very useful
and it is in the interest of the package
author to get as many people as possible
to use the thing
to maximize the impact of the work
so when we're using appeals open source
software it can be helpful
to think for a second about where in the
life cycle
this project is is this an experiment or
a mature
project like is it still actively being
developed or is it something of the past
so how should we handle this what are
things you could look for when you're
shopping for our packages
and what are indicators that reveal
something about the health of a project
or that may give you a sense of what to
expect
and what are red flags to avoid common
pitfalls
i think we can roughly distinguish three
categories of indicators
the first category of indicators are
technical indicators
and those are things that we can measure
relatively objectively so for example we
can look at the dependency network
and the current homepage of a package
already shows you the reverse
dependencies of a package
and so those are other packages that
depend on that package and so that
gives you a sense of if the package is
trusted by other developers
but just counting the number of reverse
dependencies always doesn't always tell
you the whole story because some of
these reverse dependencies
are way more important than others or
sometimes you find a package that is
used by 10 other packages all by the
same author
just like with scientific citations so
an alternative metric that you could
look at
are to count the recursive reverse
dependencies
or you could weigh the reverse
dependencies by their own
relative importance so you get something
of a pagerank statistic
and besides dependency relations other
technical indicators that you could look
at
are like download statistics or project
activity in terms of releases
or or commit activity and i think it's
especially interesting to look at how
these numbers
change over time so that you get a sense
of the life cycle of a project
to see if the product is gaining
traction or if it's on its way out
or if it has found like a stable role
within the ecosystem
let's actually look at an example that's
close to my heart and it's in the curl
package
so if you need a web line in r you
probably need something with curl
bindings
but there's actually two cram packages
that can do this one is called
our curl and the other one is just
called curl so which one should you use
well if you look at the grand homepage
you find a very similar description and
even a similar number of
reverse dependencies and you can confirm
this in r as well
but if we start looking at the recursive
reverse dependencies
we can see a much bigger difference and
the reason for this is that the curl
package is used as the foundation
for some important web framework
scenarios such as the header package
and also if we look at the reverse
dependencies over time
we can see that the use of curl has been
steadily rising over the past few years
whereas the number of packages that use
our curl has been pretty stale
and we can see a similar trend if we
look at the download statistics for
these packages over the years and the
story here is that the r
curl package is very old it has been on
grant since 2004 and has a paper about
it from 2006
and it was some very pioneering work at
the time
however a lot has changed since then and
the package has some very fundamental
problems
and the maintainer of our curl is not
very active anymore
so we wrote the curl package
specifically as a replacement for our
curl with a modern design to be simpler
and more robust
and it works very well and most users
have switched over to this new package
since then
but the old r curl package is still
around
however it's not in very good shape and
if you use it today
you quickly start running into some of
these problems
and so i think this is one example where
metrics can help you
make a more informed decision and
potentially save you a lot of
problems down the line but of course
these technical metrics uh
don't always work for example many r
packages are very niche and they're
useful only to a very particular
specialized group of people
so the package may not have many
downloads or reverse dependencies
but if this is something in your field
it may be exactly what you need
and the second category of indicators i
want to talk about are social indicators
and i consider these to be all the
things that i have to do something
with the people behind the project and
the way
in which the development and the
participation gets organized
and in my experience these are by far
the most important things to look for in
a healthy
open source project but these are not
easy to quantify like a lot of it just
comes down to
getting to know the community a little
bit so
open source projects are for better or
worse
most of the time maintained by one or
two people and this
there's this fantastic book by nadia
ekpal from earlier this year that i
really like
that talks about the reality behind open
source development and why this is the
case and the consequence that this has
and this is again one of those big
differences with commercial software a
lot of people are
used to thinking of software as written
by anonymous engineers from a big
company
and that is just not how it works for us
open source software is written by
people
like you and me and you should think of
our packages
more like a scientific publication or a
piece of work
by a local artist or a musician it
really matters
who is making that thing so
the most important social indicator is
basically
like who is the author like what
organizations they're part of
what people they they collaborate with a
lot
um like if they're still active or not
then what they're currently working on
and based on the type of package you may
care about their formal qualifications
and if they have an online presence like
a blog or social media
another social indicator is basically
how is the product managed
like is there a public place for
reporting bugs and do these typically
get resolved
and if the product is open to
contributions from external people
and what that process looks like and to
me this is very important
i believe every art package should have
a public place where everybody can
post their issues so you can see what
problems other users are running into
and people can help each other out
but let me be clear that you should not
expect every our package author to be a
full-time tech support person
like answering all these questions and
reviewing suggestions can be very
exhausting and sometimes you just
don't have time to work on a project for
a few days or a few weeks or a few
months
but for me the important thing is
transparency
like if i have no way of seeing what are
the common problems
or questions with a package
that is a red flag there may be some
exceptions
if the package is relatively small and
maintained by a professor that's really
the expert in the field
it may be okay but generally speaking
i think a functional issue tracker is
really a minimal requirement for a
healthy open source project
finally other social indicators you
could think of are available resources
for
learning about the package for example
if there's good documentation
either by the package author themselves
or by users
writing blog posts but for example also
if there's many questions and answers on
stack overflow
that may be a great source of
information and a sign that other people
are using this package
and then there's a third category of
indicators and these are perhaps more
specific to
r because we have a little research
software and these are scientific
indicators so for packages that are
specifically implementing some
scientific method
you are probably interested in the
validity of those results
and for example if the package is
fitting some model you want to be sure
that
the estimates are accurate and that the
package is handling
all edge cases properly
and this is of course very difficult to
judge but there are some things we can
look at
for example some packages have gone
through a peer review process
for example in the journal of cisco
software or in our open site
that's a good sign it's not a guarantee
that the package will be
in good standing forever but at least
the author has gone through an effort at
some point to have a colleague
have a critical look at the code and of
course we can look at citations
of packages in scientific publications
this is very tricky because many
researchers don't cite software
and if they decide they probably just
cite r or tidy verse
and not the individual packages but what
is interesting
is that many journals these days are
starting to require resources
researchers to include the analysis code
with our publication
for reproducibility purposes and so you
can imagine
if a lot of code becomes available this
way we can start to analyze some of this
code
to see which our packages are commonly
used in scientific research
so i think the scientific quality of our
packages
is by far the most difficult to judge
but is very important all right so why
am i talking about all of this
so in our open psi we want to help
researchers to get the most out of
r so we do curation and we organize peer
review of our packages
and we provide some development
infrastructure and
recently we've been increasingly feeling
the need for better tools to actively
monitor
the quality of our packages
and this is both for our internal
projects
but also for the our ecosystem as a
whole
to be able to better advise researchers
on what to use
so we've started working on this new
project called our universe
and on the one hand our universe is an
extension of our internal build
infrastructure
so in our open site we have a doc server
which automatically builds package down
documentation for all of our packages
and we have a grant-like server which
automatically builds the binaries for
all of our packages
and this works very well and with our
universe we basically want to enable
other organizations to take advantage of
this same tooling
but we want our universe to not become
just a build system
but also a place where you can learn
more about these packages
so we're going to try to combine some of
these hard data that you get from the
build system
with other source of information about
authors
and activity in the life cycle and all
these things that we've talked about
and then we have someone else to work on
the scientific metrics so they are
developing
tools that can help us find citations
and mentions of packages
in scientific publications and besides
showing information about a single
project
we also want to help with the discovery
of other software
and so by cross-referencing similar
packages or
other work by the same author or the
same organization
maybe we can build something of a
recommender system
and finally we want this to be a place
that says something about the impact and
the
importance of an r project in order to
help package authors get credit
for research software in the same way as
this happens for scientific publications
so this was my talk thank you for
listening i hope it got you thinking a
little bit about the world behind open
source development
and if we got you interested in our
universe project keep an eye on our
website
iuniverse.dev uh where we will
start adding more of the things that
we're working on over the upcoming year